okay so now let's get to the reaction
from Donald Trump
- this just blockbuster scandal where
Donald Trump is accused not just of
wanting to collude with Ukraine for his
benefit in the 2020 election but if
allegedly withholding 250 million
dollars in aid unless Ukraine's smears
Joe Biden to help Trump in 2020 we
already looked at what trumps TV lawyer
Rudy Giuliani said about this he went on
Chris Cuomo and he said I never had
Ukraine do anything about Biden then
immediately said of course I asked
Ukraine to investigate Joe Biden and
when Chris Cuomo calls him out for it he
says I never denied saying that I talked
to Ukraine about Joe Biden that was all
within like 35 seconds okay we talked
about that earlier in the show we now
are getting to video of a visibly red
and disheveled looking Donald Trump
particularly red and disheveled here is
Trump with of course a helicopter in the
background making it extremely difficult
to hear anything anybody is saying and
Trump admits that yes the topic of Joe
Biden did come up during the media
during the phone call with the Ukrainian
president back in July that part is
clear and then of course it's just
details take a look at this we had a
great conversation
conversation I had was largely
congratulatory was largely corruption
all of the corruption taking place was
largely the fact that we don't want our
people like Vice President Biden is done
creating to be corruption already in the
Ukraine and Ukraine Ukraine's got a lot
of problems the new president is saying
that he's going to be able to rid the
country of corruption and I said that
would be a great thing we had a great
conversation we had a conversation on
many things in fact I believe Ukraine
put out a statement yesterday saying
that we covered many different topics it
was a warm and friendly conversation we
facts I back Ukraine from the beginning
so there Trump says yeah we did talk
about Joe Biden we talked about how
people like Joe Biden and his son are
bad and they should be kept out of power
which is of course not a denial of
exactly what it is that is being
reported Trump does not going far enough
in admitting the full details of that
the report was Biden was discussed and
that part is of course true the next
question is are the details about not
agreeing to a White House meeting with
the Ukrainian president and withholding
250 million in military aid because
Ukraine has not yet smeared Biden is
that part true but we've got part one
which is Trump admits Biden did come up
during that phone call now here's
another clip this is more yelling over
the chopper Trump asked if Rudy Giuliani
is involved here and Trump says he would
love to have Rudy Giuliani involved and
of course once again another point is
confirmed we suspected that Rudy
Giuliani was involved Rudy Giuliani more
recently on Chris Cuomo's program on CNN
after denying that he was involved in
talking to Ukraine about Biden admits it
and here is Donald Trump saying it would
be great if Rudy Giuliani was involved
I would have no problem with the Rudy's
a very great shooter Rudy wants to see
the same thing as a lot of other people
with respect to Ukraine Ukraine has had
a tremendous corruption problem somehow
they were involved in a lot of different
things that took place in our country
and hopefully it could be straight down
and I will say the new President had a
very good talk the new president got
elected based on the fact that he would
in corruption that was probably his
number one thing then Trump just repeats
listen to me like a crazy person and
then concocts some cockamamie conspiracy
theory about Joe Biden while still
defending the phone call with the
Ukrainian president
listen to me
I assume many people are on the line I
know that before I make the call in that
forget the diligence agencies everybody
listening that call was a greatcoat is a
perfect call a perfect call what wasn't
perfect is the horrible thing that joe
biden said and now we made a lie when he
said he never spoke to his son I mean
give me a break he's already said he
spoke to his son and now he said
yesterday very firmly right thank you
son of course you spoke to your son so
he made the mistake of saying he never
spoke to his son he spoke to his son but
more importantly what he said about the
billions of dollars that he wouldn't
give them unless they fired the
prosecutor and then he bragged about had
they fired the prosecutor they got the
money
these are the rantings of a disheveled
madman I'm not trying to make fun of
anyone when I say this but Trump is not
only now sounding like the guy on the
subway platform yelling at you about the
fifth coming of Zeus or something while
urinating on the third rail Trump is
also looking like that guy and here he
is with more conspiracy theories saying
Biden China sellout something something
not only you take a look at China they
took a tremendous amount of money out of
China
now they ever took over at China
negotiation he would sell us out look at
all the money he paid in China the son
he knew nothing the son is the stiff he
knew nothing and he's making hundreds of
thousands and millions of dollars he did
the same thing in Ukraine he knows
nothing so this is the new corruption
this is the new treason this is the new
bribery and we are all just sort of
getting used to it and just looking at
Trump in this video you can tell that
he's not well never mind you know
listening to the absolutely ridiculous
things that he's saying and we've gotten
used to it you look online you look at
the comments on these videos and it's
overwhelmingly things from left and
right yeah this is sort of crazy but
this is just Trump is it drugs we don't
know is it that this is what shame looks
like we know we say Donald Trump doesn't
really seem to be able to feel shame
maybe he is able to feel shame and this
is what he looks like and sounds like
when he's feeling shame that this has
gone public I don't know the answer but
as far as you know III do think that
these conspiracy theories about Joe
Biden are becoming prominent enough that
we probably want to just do a little bit
of a debunking of them and of course I
know that there are people who will say
David how are you now a Biden supporter
when we talk about this but tomorrow I
think it's important we don't even know
who's gonna be the Democratic nominee
and I want it to be someone
progessive compared to Joe Biden who's a
center-left Democrat but we can't let
these conspiracy theories about Joe
Biden gain momentum and gain steam so
probably on tomorrow's show if not
Wednesdays I will outline exactly what
the allegations are here against Joe
Biden and we will thoroughly debunk them